>> Ed: GOOD EVENING, WELCOME
TO WASHINGTON.
I AM ED HENRY IN AGAIN FOR
BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOKE UP EARLY
AND AGAIN WAS QUICKLY SETTING
THE TONE BY TWITTER.
WISHING A HAPPY NEW YEAR TO THE
"HATERS," AND FAKE NEWS MEDIA.
EQUIPPING THAT PEOPLE SUFFERING
FROM TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME
SHOULD SIT BACK AND ENJOY THE
RIDE BECAUSE HE SAID GOOD THINGS
ARE HAPPENING.
HE WENT ON TO CHEERLEAD THE
STRONG JOBS MARKET AND TWEETED
OUT A CHARGE THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
REALLY FOR OPEN BORDERS.
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF FACING A
NEW POWER DYNAMIC.
THE PARTIAL SHUTDOWN IS WELL
INTO ITS 11TH DAY.
THERE'S STILL NO END IN SIGHT AS
DEMOCRATS PREPARED THURSDAY TO
OFFICIALLY TAKE CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE AND THEY HOPE TO QUICKLY
PASS LEGISLATION TO REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT ON THEIR TERMS.
NONE OF THE $5 BILLION THE
PRESIDENT IS DEMANDING FOR A
BORDER WALL.
THAT MAY BE WHY THE PRESIDENT
DID TRY A SLIGHTLY MORE
DIPLOMATIC APPROACH ON TWITTER
BY THE AFTERNOON, SAYING TO
DEMOCRATS, LET'S MAKE A DEAL.
HE INVITED CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS
TO COME WEDNESDAY TO THE
WHITE HOUSE WHICH IS WHERE WE
FIND OUR CORRESPONDENT
KEVIN CORKE.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> GOOD EVENING.
START NEW REALITY FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, AS YOU POINTED
OUT, DEMOCRATIC-CONTROLLED HOUSE
TO SAY NOTHING OF THE
ONGOING GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
PARTIAL SHUTDOWN.
THAT WILL NOT STOP THE
PRESIDENT'S PLANS FOR 2019, SAY
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS.
NOR APPARENTLY WILL IT STOP HIS
PENCHANT FOR PUNCHING OPPONENTS
ON TWITTER.
IF HIS NEW YEAR'S TWITTER FEED
WERE A BLOCKBUSTER FILM,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD HAVE BEEN
A GOOD OLD-FASHIONED GOOD
COP-BAD COP MOVIE.
STARTING A PRESIDENT CONTENT TO
HAMMER HIS SO-CALLED HATERS AND
IN ALL CAPS, CHIDING DEMOCRATS
FOR IGNORING ALL THE CRIME AND
DRUGS THAT OPEN BORDERS BRING
AND AT THE VERY SAME TIME,
SHOWCASING HIS SOFTER SIDE, EVEN
SUGGESTING TO ONE OF HIS CHIEF
PROTAGONISTS ON CAPITOL HILL,
NANCY PELOSI, THAT THE TIME
MIGHT BE RIGHT TO MAKE A DEAL TO
END THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
AN OFFER MANIFESTLY REJECTED BY
THE PRESUMPTIVE SPEAKER.
>> I'M READY TO GO.
THEY CAN COME OVER RIGHT NOW.
THEY COULD'VE COME OVER ANYTIME.
I SPENT CHRISTMAS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I SPENT NEW YEAR'S EVE NOW IN
THE WHITE HOUSE AND, YOU KNOW,
I'M HERE.
I'M READY TO GO.
>> READY TO GO IS ONE THING BUT
WILLING TO COMPROMISE MAY HAVE
BE A BRIDGE TOO FAR, PRACTICALLY
FOR A PRESIDENT EAGER TO HELP
BORDER WALL FUNDING THE LATEST
IN A STRING OF TRUMP JURIES OVER
THE PAST YEAR, INCLUDING A
SUCCESSFUL KAVANAUGH
CONFIRMATION OF THE
SUPREME COURT.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT, A NEW
U.S. NCA TRADE DEAL.
THE END OF THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL
AND THE DISMANTLING OF ISIS.
A PRECURSOR TO OTHER MILITARY
MOVES IN 2019, INCLUDING A PLAN
TO HAVE A PRECIPITOUS DRAWDOWN
IN SYRIA.
>> WE ARE BRINGING OUR YOUNG,
GREAT TROOPS HOME AFTER SO MANY
YEARS.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE IN SYRIA
FOR THREE TO FOUR MONTHS AND
THAT WAS FOUR OR FIVE YEARS AGO.
IT'S TIME.
WE HAVE TO BRING THEM HOME.
>> FEW AGENDA ITEMS WILL BE
ACCOMPLISHED THIS YEAR INCLUDING
MOVEMENT ON MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
LEGISLATION UNTIL THE GOVERNMENT
REOPENS, PUTTING THE ONUS ON THE
PRESIDENT AND CONGRESSIONAL
LAWMAKERS TOO, AS THE PRESIDENT
SUGGESTED, MAKE A DEAL OR SUFFER
THE POLITICAL FALLOUT WHILE
EVERYDAY AMERICANS SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES.
A BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING FOR YOU,
ED.
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS HAVE BEEN
INVITED TO THE WHITE HOUSE TO
ATTEND A BRIEFING BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
ON THE BORDER WALL.
THAT BRIEFING SET FOR 3:00 P.M.
TOMORROW AFTERNOON, ALTHOUGH
SOURCES TELL OUR CHAD PERGRAM
IT'S UNCLEAR IF THEY WILL ALL
MAKE IT BECAUSE OF HOLIDAY